i believe this is a huge issue for a lot  of people in life where does motivation  stop and execution begin everybody's got  a different answer but here's what i can  tell you it's really easy to be  motivated either you've got it or you  can watch it it's really hard to execute  it is the variable that separates people  people are always telling me that  they're going to do this and that and  this and that and you know how many do  who said  people talk [ __ ] yeah i know which one  is first which one is second but if  you're not executing you're not  motivational like i don't know what that  other stuff is you're doing but real  motivation it makes you do something